I'm excited I've never eaten a Bob's
Burgers program I hope I don't need a
toothpick
because then I'll die on camera like
many of you out there I instantly fell
in love with Bob Belcher and his family
run burger joint on the cartoon series
Bob's Burgers as a chef many parts of
Bob's life in the kitchen resonate with
my own so you can imagine how excited I
was to link up with the man who voices
Bob the legendary John Benjamin to nerd
out about the show and to bring some of
these cartoon burgers to life you know
as a chef right now I'm currently
holding a hat of the ambassadors of all
the chefs out there we are huge fans of
work that's a really good consequence of
the show yeah I mean like it mails how
to be a small business owner but it's
fun and being a chef because I had a
food truck for three years sort of Bob
well one episode I would go through the
same growing pains that the Belcher
family would Karthik's thankfully
everything on Bob's at some point has
happened to somebody else I'm saying
like this show just like makes every
chef who's been in the industry for more
than a year they can relate to Bob you
always see the regular menu in the
background it's like burger cheese
burger it's very very plain yeah and
then he has this burger of the day at
some point you get so tired of making
the same thing over and over yeah that
you have to let your creative side
unleash right I used to do a daily
special it gets to show the customer
like who you really are
the Loren Bouchard who you know you know
and he's the creator of the show we
always have a running argument about
whether he's really good or really bad
right or like mediocre right and Lauren
always sort of falls on the fact that
Bob I think is sort of more like what
you're saying his characters more about
like he's really good at it and the
burger of the day is like a creative
inspiration that keeps him fresh is a
big part of him then I always had
decided on the fact that he's
no one's ever in the restaurant hey guys
one with the numbers as a chef I wanted
to see how it would become a reality I
did a whole pop-up here in New York City
where I got to make the burgers from the
show so I wanna take you on a burger
journey through my eyes as Bob you know
I do have a burger limit I can only like
eight so this is a baby you can chive my
car burger
it has fried pickles as wheels feta
stuffed in the burger and it has a sour
cream and chive sauce nice like this is
like that it's not rageous burger like
you there's [ __ ] wheels on a burger
it's almost stony like you know like
this is something I would make after
smoking a bun it's possible young Bob
did that yeah young Bob probably today I
did that how I would tell the customers
to eat this burger put it on the burger
yeah just stuff it in the burger all
right here we go let's do it nobody
excited I've never eaten a Bob's Burgers
burger so I hope you like it
yeah I hope I don't need a toothpick
well because then I'll die on camera oh
man that's really good right really good
it has like that sour cream and onion
you know nice oniony flavor I mean this
is pretty rich the fed is salty and then
the pickles are cutting through the fat
it's a well conceived work totally solid
yeah really good I like that the show is
like a cookbook now it shows you who bob
is he's a creative burger freak uh
that's right
burger - all right never been feta foot
feta ish burger this particular Burger
has feta crumbled throughout the meat it
has a ciabatta bun
I use a burr bond that looks like
Shibata baby spinach Dijon mayo sriracha
sauce so there's a lot going on it's not
going on simpler presentation but lot
going on there's a lot it's its flavor
for sure lots of flavor go for it
[Music]
well I mean I immediately like the
muster a lot mm-hm
yeah like much Tangier than the last one
this is maybe a little sweeter plus you
got a little heat which is good yeah I
like this one a lot but no wheels yeah
no that's just more animated I guess I
don't know there is something that was
unappealing to the guests when they saw
the betta in the burger in the burger
they're just like it's pink my cheese is
pink it's too rare really mm-hmm
that doesn't bother me but it's so good
like the flavors are there no really
good they were wrong they were wrong
they were dead wrong so as a as a cook
as a Bob's burger fat right it's been my
dream to make my own burger of the day
hopefully one day it'll make it on the
show
no but I've created a burger I've
channeled my Bob Belcher I think I've
practicode man ie Bob Belcher stamp of
approval let's do it all right
[Music]
this is what I think should be on the
next burger of the day I'm calling this
fry me to the moon inspired by Frank
Sinatra yeah also means something to me
because I love the movie Wall Street I
just moved to New York and then the
beginning of the movie has that fly me
to it and it's a psycho okay could have
done the greed is Gouda Oh greediest
Gouda see ya there you go you know you
call this that - well / because this has
good at it okay everybody after the show
after we cut the cameras Alvin and I
realized well actually I realized that
the greed is Gouda it was not an
original idea by me it was already in
Bob's Burgers I at the time I took
credit for it I feel bad but I just want
you to know that's how good the show is
it came up with the idea that I thought
I came up with but it wasn't my idea at
all it was Bob's Burgers so you just
wanted to point it out and say I
apologize for claiming that idea as mine
it wasn't so I'm gonna keep doing this
with my drink because I don't have any
good ideas left so what I have here is a
croissant which looks like the moon like
a crescent exactly right
this is called midnight moon Gouda by
Cypress Grove here's the crazy part it's
like everyone thinks your burger should
be round I want to make this burger the
shape of a crescent moon okay okay good
thing yeah
so you see I'm going extra I'm caroling
my boggart the mice is my this is my
pickle wheel and that is a cow meat or
human this is this is not human meat
okay that was the original concept of
the showed you know that no yeah the
show first started where the family were
cannibals really yeah no we like the
first iteration of
my god is true that's a trip that's yeah
and then the network was like no no
that's a terrible show this is inspired
by the Tennessee deep-fried burger okay
never had that I like to season it
cocaine this is salt
okay that's fine since its then you only
want to season one side a little bit of
pepper cocaine would have been you know
a proposed Wall Street but whatever
whatever right live separate interests
oh nice
what this is doing is it's creating a
cross then I have a deep-fried pickle
spear this is done see how it like it's
the shape of the bad boy yeah you're
absolutely right so I got this cheese
and I melted it down and then made a
cheese sauce this one might kill me
throwing this lid on here this I feel is
super Bob's burger we're throwing on the
moon man fly me to the moon American
flag yep this is a fry be to the moon
burger it has the moon man everything
shaped like a crescent I get it I hope
you like it I'm gonna try it
[Music]
you a pickle in there I did okay what do
you think
[Music]
I'd be hosts yeah like [ __ ] dude Zab
[ __ ] took pictures with it number how
to fried burger before so that's good I
would definitely advocate for this to be
on the show fry me to the moon
greed is Gouda through the school
mission accomplished we did it's it's
gonna happen
thanks man Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so goodbye watch Bob's Burgers if you
want or don't I mean whatever just go
away go get the camera away from me I'm
serious